ce 64e de finale pourrait être le match
de leur vie
depuis le tirage au sort mi décembre le
choc face à l'aj auxerre est dans toutes
les têtes
joueur entraîneur de l'ess billancourt
ont du mal à rester en place
mais pas question de changer les
habitudes à l'entraînement ce soir là au
programme ateliers de vivacité et
conservation de balle comme tous les
mardis on sait qu'on fait du foncier de
mardi avec un petit peu de jeux de
ballons demain soir on fait un petit
match amical et jeudi comme d'habitude
ça sera plus de jeux de ballons avec les
gardiens et tout ça mais on change donc
pas plus que ça d'habitude que des
entraînements auxerre n'est autre que le
champion de france en titre de la
catégorie tout simplement ce qui se fait
de mieux dans l'hexagone
mais ce palmarès n'impressionne pas les
jeunes saint quentinois ils feront tout
pour vaincre l'ogre bourguignon illimité
epinal en coupe de france
tombeurs de l'olympique lyonnais il ya
quelques jours ça nous donne beaucoup
d'idées franchement quand je vois ces
clubs là c'est beau pour le foot on va
dire puisque c'est rare que des clubs
comme ça ils arrivent à s'imposer face à
des gros clubs nous c'est une chose créé
la surprise pour moi ouais ils ont des
jambes et deux bras comme nous voilà on
est plus motivé que jamais alors
carrément la cgppa c'est comme un rêve
pour nous tous on est heureux mais si on
peut aller plus loin royal et on va tout
faire pour
lors des quatre premiers tours
l'entraîneur n'avait pas anticipé la
séance de tirs au but
un moment crucial où jordan doussain
gardien de but de le sg sera plus que
jamais le dernier rempart c'est un
exercice que j'aime bien mais si on
pouvait ne pas y arriver ça serait mieux
mais si elle est penalty aura les
penaltys offre avec un il ya des
techniques mais bon souvent c'est
l'instinct pour la plupart les jeunes
guyancourt toi jouent ensemble depuis
cinq voire six saisons plus que onze
joueurs c'est une bande de copains qui
voudra à tout prix continuer l aventure